I told you earlier this week that during
his Tuesday night speech to the joint
session of Congress Donald Trump invited
and honored
Ryan Owens's Widow Karen Owens now Ryan
Owens is the deceased Navy SEAL who was
killed during this botched raid in Yemen
that Donald Trump ordered casually over
dinner couldn't even be bothered to be
in the Situation Room for and for me it
was the most vile and cringe-worthy
moment of the speech total pandering and
use of someone's pain and agony cameras
were on Karen Owens for close to four
minutes and she wept and applauded while
sitting next to and periodically being
touched by Trump's daughter Ivanka Trump
just a few seconds from that as a
reminder we are blessed to be joined
tonight by Corrine Owens the widow of US
Navy special operator senior Chief
William Ryan Owens Brian died as he
lived a warrior and a hero battling
against terrorism and securing our
nation
[Applause]
yeah so it went on for nearly four
minutes Trump talked about her husband's
sacrifice which of course was a result
of Trump opting casually to do this raid
which the Obama administration had been
presented with the opportunity to do
opted not to because in Obama's
estimation the potential rewards were
heavily outweighed by the risks this was
not only an attempt from Trump the sort
of gain presidential status which worked
in some ways this was total war
propaganda okay and even some liberal
commentators talked about what a
presidential moment that was for Donald
Trump some people were gushing here's
Van Jones for example became president
of the United States in that moment
period there are a lot of people who
have a lot of reason to be frustrated
with him to be fearful of him to be mad
at him but that was one the most
extraordinary moments you have ever seen
in American politics period and he did
something extraordinary and for people
who have been hoping that he would
become unifying hoping that he might
find some way to become presidential
they should be happy with that moment
some people who watch our show responded
to that by emailing me and saying look
van Jones was able to put partisanship
aside and praise the president well he
was just wrong the intercept had a good
article about this by Glenn Greenwald
someone I don't always agree with but it
was a very solid article and it points
out that this isn't something unique to
Trump President Obama honored injured
vets with standing ovations George W
Bush did the same thing many presidents
have and it may have been done by Trump
for personal gain but the broader use of
these soldiers and families as props is
part of the more general propaganda that
legitimizes in the minds of some the
neverending global war on terror note
that none of the 30 people who died in
the Yemen raid were mentioned by Trump
with civilians the innocent civilians
but they were from Yemen right not the
US and those are just some of the costs
of the global war on terror a standard
u.s. war propaganda tactic is focused
only on our soldiers and their spouse
and Families but ignore the countless
innocent people killed overseas by our
military actions and the numbers are way
way bigger there
this helps to foment support for the
sort of abstract and ongoing global war
on terror Ryan Owens died heroically
carrying out actions to help our
national security this is a deserved
tribute it's terrible how we treat our
veterans when they come back if we pay
attention to veterans in this or any
other way and it helps to better take
care of our veterans when they come back
then that's absolutely great but the
impact Pat of these never-ending
amorphous campaigns includes hundreds of
thousands of civilians killed in Iraq
the 30 civilians killed in this botched
raid and when you just think about Owens
dying heroically and you think about
Trump they're applauding in the entire
scene this is part of the broader war
propaganda that supports the never
ending global war on terror and let's
remember that Ryan Owens's father wasn't
invited and refused to go to this
address
yes refused to even meet with Trump
because he couldn't possibly stomach it
yeah I mean he wants an investigation
into this and he certainly does not want
to be used as a political prop so it
definitely wasn't poor taste the other
propaganda effect of this is that it
frames only the US as the victims of
these campaigns right were the good guys
were victimized by terror from other
countries and then because we've got to
do the the duty of sending people like
Ryan Owens over sometimes people like
Ryan Owens died and then were victimized
again we're only the victims were never
the perpetrators of any wrongdoing I am
NOT like blame the US for everything
thing I'm not to blame the u.s. blame
u.s. foreign policy singularly for
radical extremism around the world
that's not what I'm doing and I hope
people won't hear me saying this and
think that that's what I'm saying
propaganda is being used to manipulate
people by priming and allowing them to
empathize only towards American lives
rather than all of those affected by the
consequences in the loss of war and yes
Donald Trump's botched decision here led
to an American death but it also led to
30 Yemeni deaths
send me your thoughts on this agree
disagree am I missing something I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman I am also on Twitter
as the david pakman show at david pakman
show